[Música]
las empresas de modo en francia han sido
pequeñas casas familiares durante siglos
que la mayoría de veces se han
derrumbado o han sido devoradas por
grandes grupos de lujo pero hay quienes
se han enfrentado y aún enfrentan en las
buenas y las malas crisis económicas
globalización
subcontratación la revolución de
internet y hoy la pandemia de kobe 19
como transmite hoy su herencia sus
métodos y su saber hacer
[Música]
hoy transmitir significa darle las
llaves a la tercera generación para
echarlos y poder perpetuar el espíritu
del diseño que no se es propio pero
sobre todo saber calzar el diseño no es
nada sin las manos y la técnica no es
nada sin el diseño primer ejemplo la
casa a especialistas en zapatos de cuero
condiciones flexibles algunos en leche
de árbol de caucho la empresa como y la
conocemos existe desde 1968 en el valle
de loira en turén a pero la historia
empezó mucho antes
en los años 30 mi papá tuvo tuberculosis
a una edad muy temprana y el hecho de
estar afectado tan joven lo llevó
siempre a buscar lo positivo en su vida
a ir a buscar la belleza donde había
digamos tristeza infelicidad y eso le
formó mucho esa voluntad de superar las
dificultades de recuperarse en cualquier
momento nos evolución placer y
dificultad y habiendo estado enfermo con
muy poca escolaridad fue autodidacta y
desde muy joven no tuvo más remedio que
arreglárselas y tener que ganarse la
vida
entonces empezó a imaginar lo que podía
hacer con los materiales que encontraba
durante la guerra y que
empezó a desarrollar modelos para la
sociedad de tours hasta que se convirtió
y se ganó el título de artesano zapatero
por encontrar el mismo soluciones
técnicas al servicio de una determinada
estética
con decisión técnica o servicio sin ser
tan estético
la empresa patriarcal en sus inicios se
transforma gradualmente con los cambios
de la sociedad francesa que hacer y con
with you are in netbook romper los
códigos cis siempre en una época en los
años 60 70 cuando todo se disparaba era
como aportar comodidad y por tanto
bienestar en cuanto a los zapatos
siempre hubo un poco de inconformismo
siempre hubo un giro siempre hubo una
pequeña diferencia aunque sólo fuera en
la historia de mis padres ya que mi papá
está en el origen del espíritu de la
casa
pero mi mamá era la garante de la
construcción financiera económica y
comercial de la casa económico social
dólares y katrin el en está lejos de
ceder su lugar pero ya está preparando
cuidadosamente su sucesión su hija
charlotte que aún no tiene 25 años pero
ya ha viajado por el mundo varias veces
tiene una sólida formación en comercio
internacional está en la línea
si tuviera que aportar una ambición
personal sería la de poder desarrollar
proyectos de carácter humanitario o en
todo caso que tratan de cuestiones
medioambientales
me especialicé en emprendimiento social
y me gustaría poder aportar una fuerza
que podría ser por ejemplo la puesta en
marcha de una fundación o cualquier otro
proyecto que me resulte cercano y que
tenga una motivación humana
segunda propuesta la casa weston en la
galería y boutique madre en parís oliver
sajous el brillante director artístico
de la marca imaginó una exposición que
tituló sioux
siempre lamenté que en las tiendas de
lujo o menos de lujo cuando se
organizaban eventos culturales siempre
era en la parte trasera de una boutique
con una iluminación no muy buena sin la
importancia que estábamos prefería abrir
una verdadera exposición en el govern de
un tamaño apropiado con un verdadero
texto de presentación es una ayuda a la
visita y con obras que pongan de relieve
el saber hacer de weston el origen de
vuestros que es francés somos una
empresa que se remonta a 1891 quería
realmente que tratáramos aquí el saber
hacer de weston con zapatos casi hechos
a mano y que son en su mayoría muy
antiguos de 1937 en 1946 como es el caso
de los mocasines para poner de relieve
el saber hacer de la fábrica por ejemplo
un zapato que está en el escaparate que
es un zapato araña es un homenaje a
louis rams pero está hecho a partir de
lo que sabemos hacer desde hace décadas
la costura noruega que permite que los
zapatos sean perfectamente impermeables
con hilos y es también un guiño a las
arañas que animamos en la curtiduría
cuando tenemos nuestra propia curtiduría
las arañas son muy apreciadas porque
protegen el cuero de una especie de
putrefacción al comercio todos los
insectos y otro tipo de zapatos aquí es
el campo es un modelo muy típico de
weston que somos los últimos en fabricar
a partir de una sola pieza del cuero que
se moldea sobre una horma de manera casi
sin costuras también tenemos este modelo
que es el de triple triple triple suela
triple suela tal y como la tengo en el
pie de forma corriente y básica que data
de los años 50 y que aquí está de forma
totalmente desacoplada para hacer este
extraordinario zapato
el mundo del calzado quizás incluso más
competitivo que el de la ropa se
reinventa constantemente tanto humana
como artísticamente